yemen's conflict is reaching a critical
phase we joined Emirati forces along the
country's west coast this area and the
port city of had a de aqui - what
happens next
[Music]
the ceasefire brokered in December hangs
by a thread both sides blaming each
other for violations and amidst this
grinding war a desperate population
struggling to survive is scrapping in
the dirt for whatever handouts they can
get
we were taken to the Red Sea flour mills
on the edge of the city
this frontline position is now
controlled by the coalition inside the
stores the grain is spoiling in the hint
aid agencies say although the Fighting's
paused they can't cross the front lines
to access these supplies the United
Nations says in these silos alone
there's enough grain to feed 3.7 million
people and remember in Yemen 10 million
people are on the brink of famine but
although there is a ceasefire there are
daily violations which means it can't be
distributed one of those serious was the
shelling of this position a couple of
weeks ago and you can see inside here
the grain is still on fire it's been
completely destroyed and has gone to
waste
emirati forces claim it is the Houthis
less than a kilometer away across the
sands of no-man's land who were blocking
distribution and the ceasefire could
collapse at any time
the break in the fighting though between
iranian-backed Houthis and the saudi-led
coalition is the only flicker of hope
for Yemen it is a place where light no
longer shines famine and starvation stop
the population this field hospital
they're barely coping the place is full
of sick and hungry children 13 days
after she was admitted
bashira is still struggling to breathe
[Music]
her tiny lungs weak from lack of food so
bad and there is no enough support like
drivers food milk that needs children
like like hard what happens to children
like bashira if they don't come here yes
they will die the war erupted out of an
Arab Spring uprising but this conflict
cannot be resolved through military
might the Coalition believes controlling
the main commercial ports will clinch
victory and restore Yemen's
internationally recognized government
but the path to a political settlement
will not be easy the roads are littered
with IEDs and landmines emirati forces
are clearing and destroying them every
day but even if the latest talks are
successful the risk of further violence
is great but for now the stalemate
remains and it is delicate if
negotiations fail the lull in the
fighting may not last much longer and
the disaster of a full-scale offensive
on her data may become reality Alex
Rossi Sky News